their neighborhoods are scarred now they
want the National Guard but would their
crime surge be gone if they just listen
to the dawn
after a deadly weekend in the nation's
capital that's Washington D.C Joe
just checking 11 people killed from
Friday to Sunday and a Washington D.C
councilman is calling for the National
Guard to step in by the way it's rare to
see D.C councilman calling for something
besides a lift after getting carjacked
roll it
I have spoken with the DC National Guard
and wow I have to have more
conversations with the chief police
which I have today and the mayor and my
colleagues we have a long way to get
there
we just know that police alone is not
getting it done we're tired of this
and enough is enough right excuse my
language
he sounds like a Republican
a republican rapper
those are funny I hope he didn't walk
near the capitol on January 6th he might
get arrested so police alone can't do
the job the National Guard is needed to
quell the crime where have we heard that
before
oh yeah that guy the man whose policies
were so racist they could have saved
thousands of black lives in 2021 he
called for the National Guard to be
deployed to San Francisco and other
liberal hellholes to stop rampant Smash
and grab robberies and Libs lost what's
left of their damn minds but now they
want the same National Guard to come to
their rescue which proves the point damn
Trump is right again
yeah pisses me off uh how dare you clap
how dare you clap meanwhile if you're
thinking of visiting Oakland California
don't
even their football team left and that's
the Raiders so you think that would
reduce some violence but crime is so bad
in Oakland people are telling residents
to literally use air horns to warn
Neighbors about Intruders and add
security bars to doors and windows to
keep criminals out but I don't know
here's another suggestion how about
putting bars around the criminals
instead of the citizens and locking up
the thieves instead of the ice cream
remember yeah
remember the good old days when we when
we use the law to keep criminals out now
it's to keep us in Oakland is overrun by
so-called drug tourists now we've turned
an entire neighborhood into an open-air
drug Market affectionately called
fentanyl Island
I know it doesn't sound as fun as I
thought it would be it's like Fantasy
Island of your fantasies to OD on a pile
of garbage and feces it's home to burned
out cars homeless camps drug adult
junkies jonesing for a fix and worst of
all the Oakland A's
I used to like the Oakland A's I don't
know why I put that in there uh Tulsi um
it's kind of interesting to see a an
entire party kind of play catch up on
this but it was only because they just
couldn't be seen as agreeing with any
Republican and especially Trump yeah
yeah this was one of the most
frustrating things throughout my eight
years in Congress was how very blatantly
from the beginning if there was a
Democrat Bill and Republicans were in
charge they're like yeah no we like the
idea we'll take the idea but a
republican will introduce and we'll
support it yeah and vice versa this is
the kind of stuff that the American
people are so sick and tired of we see
it especially with Trump how it doesn't
matter the substance of of the idea or
the proposal or what he's calling for
there is no chance any of these Democrat
Elite would ever would ever support or
vote for it so you know who loses I mean
the people yeah you know it Trump blew
it Tyrus he should have come out and
supported really awful ideas like we
need more crime yeah and the Democrats
would say we're against Crime right oh
you're pissing me off
first of all a great monologue and uh
going into this we always leave out the
key ingredient because everyone wants to
blame the police yeah the police are
arresting these criminals 67 of them
aren't even charged that's more than
half are out the same day which means
that they can be back on the streets
committing crimes just after lunch so
just think about that for a minute and
again the Democrats have not got it they
have not got it this councilman's
finally getting mic time people in the
community colored people like myself who
are getting robbed and watching and
their children are afraid of their their
grandparents are afraid of their
grandchildren and all these horrible
things are happening and the squad is
hasn't changed yeah they're still saying
no more police they don't want them in
their neighborhoods because they have
security guards yeah but the people are
now saying enough and this is where the
councilman coming forward if you looked
at that entire scene behind him it was
minorities yeah the people that they
represent and are trying to protect that
they are screwing over because where is
that money going to ridiculous projects
to things like bankrupt electric bus
batteries yes and no one can find the
money for that guarantee you there's a
few cousins in the Biden family that are
making some good money on Biden on bus
and probably called bus Biden economics
means
pay a bunch of Rich Elites money that
are supposed to go to the people in the
community so what my advice to them is I
you need the National Guard one thousand
percent they should be there but either
National Guard with the police and
you're still going to have 67 out yeah
so what you have to do is you have to
stop voting
with your heart and start voting with
your mind and get these people out
Kat uh you uh you uh suggested this
morning that we do a special from
fentanyl Island uh
I'm working on it yes I know you really
want to go no
um it's just crazy I mean imagine having
so much public enthusiasm and and you
know so much political power behind the
idea of Criminal Justice Reform and
bungling it so badly that you're left
with no other option but to like beg for
the feds to come in yes I mean I I was
saying for a while that this would
happen that the pendulum would swing in
the other direction because there is an
argument for and I make this argument
all the time for reform in areas like
non-violent victimless crimes like drug
crimes that sort of thing but instead
what DC did was like stuff like
carjacking is it that big of a deal yeah
obviously it's going to swing in the
other direction and that's exactly what
we're seeing happen now
it's true Joe uh are you are you are you
saddened by what's happened to our
nation's capital uh I am Greg but first
I want to talk about this idea about
fighting crime with air horns that is a
terrible idea is it look they're loud
they could scare people they're good for
meeting women at EDM concerts but that's
about yeah
I even used to sleep with a bed under my
bed but then I realized if a burglar
breaks in he's just gonna get a free bat
yeah when he shoots me with his gun but
I'll say this I don't think it was an
example of the Democrats realizing Trump
was right I think it was an example of
trump and the Democrats both being wrong
at the same time because what the
government does is it gives itself power
then it doesn't use that power there are
laws already there are prosecutors that
aren't doing their jobs instead of
holding those people accountable they're
like oh we need to get used to the idea
of having troops on the street and I
think that's just a case of uh more
encroachment we just need to hold some
people accountable there you go
air horn air they're like car alarms you
know what happened with car alarms
except I want to yell fire yeah so now
you're gonna hear beep beep was that two
was that two for rape or one for assault
I didn't hear you beep would you say and
you'll hear it all through tonight and
there'll be someone open the window
going shut up I'm trying to sleep
exactly and when people holler fire I
run in the opposite direction yeah
because there's a a fire yes
up next Trump tests out a new line by
calling Chris Christie a swine hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else